first thing I need to ask you is I know
you are obsessed with Halloween do you
remember the very first thing that told
you you were obsessed with Halloween
like your first Halloween core memory um
one of my first
memories was uh carving a jackal lantern
with my dad which was the inspiration
for uh the story with Charlie and the
severed head um mine didn't go like that
unfortunately um but yeah I grew up in
Ohio and uh very clear memory of carving
a pumpkin putting it in the window
stepping back and looking at it from the
street and uh it was all downhill from
there was it a scary face it was a scary
face that's exactly what I would expect
from you yeah so again you are obsessed
with Halloween I'm sure you follow the
majority of the rules but let's say sam
got you for breaking one rule what would
that rule likely be it wouldn't happen
it just wouldn't happen I would believe
that
yeah I mean my my Halloween decoration
my yard haunt went up like the end of
September so yeah okay you you pass I
believe my house has become like that
house you know in the neighborhood where
like parents walk by with their kids um
I had one woman tell me that her kids
wouldn't even walk past my house outside
of Halloween and then like I hand out
candy my friends and I we dress up and
we terrify the
trick-or-treaters tears streaming down
their face es while their parents are
laughing at them so really helping
develop some core memories for children
um but yeah we make kids earn the candy
I feel like I needed a trick- or treat
at your house as a kid that's a core
memory that I would appreciate yeah
let's go back to the very beginning of
this script what would you say is the
biggest difference between draft one of
this screenplay and what we now love in
the final film oh good question um well
the original draft was the stories were
completely
self-contained um the original original
draft I don't even think there were that
many like overlapping like intertwining
moments um because what I had done is I
took four short stories that I had
written like in
college and I sort of just mashed them
up when I first got to La like everybody
you know I wanted to become a
screenwriter a filmmaker but then you go
to Starbucks and you see everybody wants
to become a screenwriter or a filmmaker
um and so it's really daunting and so I
thought well what if I kind of cheated
and I took some short stories that I had
written previously that all happened to
be said in Halloween and I take this
character that I uh I had done as for my
animated short so Sam started as an
animated short all handdrawn old school
cell animation no computers were
involved it was nine months of like
drawing every single uh frame and so
that I thought well I could take that
character from animated short and I'll
sort of like sprinkle him in between
like the keeper so uh the original
draft was much more of a traditional
Anthology did you always know that this
was the assortment of stories or did you
ever hit a point where I don't know you
were mixing or matching weighing whether
or not to include one um they it was all
the same stories with the exception like
the the one variation was that the The
Rock Corey story initially just took
place in a
cemetery um and the kids were playing
like ghost in the graveyard or something
like that and the original ending was
found out that the group of kids lured
the one girl to the cemetery to play
Ghost in the graveyard only to find out
that they lured her there because she
was actually dead and she forgot that
she was dead and I know that it's it's
not a terrible twist but this is coming
on the heels of the six sense and the
others and so I realized oh The Twist of
surprise you're really dead like it was
sort of a Trope at that point I mean one
version sounds like a much easier
production
feet than the other than sending a bus
over the edge into a quar I know but who
you've never seen a short bus go over a
cliff before you know I don't think
you're going to see it again either um
uh who doesn't want to see that the wish
fulfillment of a short bus go over a
cliff um uh and then the other the other
variation was that the werewolf pack
wasn't originally all female originally
it was a co-ed pack it was male and
female but I thought it would be way
more interesting if it cuz you never see
female werewolves hardly ever like you
know outside of like ginger snaps um
female werewolves are just an anomaly
it's true I love that segment School Bus
Massacre is still my number one um again
going back to the beginning because I
know that originally you weren't
planning on directing this yes there
there were four other people I mean you
might know these names maybe Stan
Winston Toby Hooper John Carpenter and
George Romero which is kind of wild to
me yeah uh so again the first well the
first producer who optioned the script
and said he wanted to make it was Stan
Winston so he was when I showed up to La
he was the first person to say like I
know you're doing animation but you
should really make movies and so that
way he was like he became my first
Mentor in the business and so I went off
uh and I I wrote the first draft gave it
to Stan he goes I love this this reminds
me of Creep Show and Tales from the
Crypt um let me try and gather some
other horror filmmaker
and get them attached to it and we'll
take it out and shop it and then he
called me up he's like all right I got
Toby Hooper George Romero I'm working on
Carpenter I'll do a segment and he goes
you might need to go meet with John
Carpenter to convince him to do it and I
was like what the are you talking
about like you want me to convince John
Carpenter to direct a segment of this
and so I had to go to I'll never forget
I had to go to the Egyptian and he was
doing a screening of the thing
and we had the same agent and the agent
said okay well you have to go meet with
Carpenter while the movie's running and
talk to him about your script and I'm
trembling I'm just terrified because
it's like go meet with God and convince
him to work with you so he's out there
smoking you know and I had to very
humbly approach him and ask him if he'd
be interested
and at the end of he's like all right
I'll do it you know and then we went out
with the script this I got the Avengers
of horror directors and nobody in town
wanted to buy it like every Studio
passed on it uh and every stud not every
Studio but I remember one keynote we got
was nobody wants to see vampires
werewolves or zombies because they're
too
old-fashioned yeah for the life of me I
cannot even begin to wrap my head around
anybody passing on that package but also
I'm deeply grateful that people passed
on it because we wouldn't have gotten
what this movie is now that's this this
movie has become a lesson in patience
persistence I've gotten really good at
turning lemons into lemonade I have
amazing lemonade stand you guys if you
ever need some like this movie like
everything that turned I thought was a
setback turned out to work in the its
advantage in the long run so the fact
that all the studios passed twice
because not only did they pass um on the
script once the movie was done and it
was sitting in limbo for years at Warner
Brothers Warner Brothers did give us
permission to shop it so we were we were
able to screen it for other Distributors
and studios in the event that one of
these other Studios Distributors wanted
to then buy it from Warner Brothers so
we screened it for all the studios and
everybody passed again have you ever
reconnected with maybe one
individual what do they say now they're
like yeah you know win some lose some oh
God I mean it's it's one thing to to
make a movie like this that builds a
following but like you've created a
Halloween staple like the reason why so
many people are here is because nobody
can let Halloween come and go without
watching your movie Sam is all over
every Halloween store next to the most
iconic slashers of all time that's one
of the coolest things ever it's a good
feeling I just got back from Salem
Massachusetts for the first time i'
never been there before who's been there
yeah it's like Disneyland for Halloween
and horror you have to go and I'm
walking around and I'm like talking to
somebody on the phone and I turn around
and I see Michael Myers and Sam get out
of a car together and then hold hands
and walk down the street together and it
was like I was I almost cried I I would
have cried I got that U let's talk about
Sam a little bit now um I'll actually
ask a similar type of question what is
the biggest difference between how you
pictured the movie version of Sam
looking compared to what he turned out
to be in the final film with that final
design pretty much spoton yeah he didn't
change too much I mean if you've seen
the animated short he's very very
similar same color pattern like a little
bit difference in the in the mask but
other than that it's it's almost
identical when you did the animated
short did you know what he looked like
underneath I didn't I honestly didn't um
it was a mystery even to me how how did
you come to the conclusion that that was
what he needed to look like um I just
started sketching like I I come from an
animation background an illustration
background so um when we were trying to
get the movie made initially I started
doing my own concept art and sketches um
and then including what Sam looked like
underneath the mask so the whole idea is
that it sort of looked like um a a
mashup between a pumpkin and a baby
skull baby skulls are so
cute they are they have like big eye
sockets and like they're adorable feel
like there just sounds right coming from
you I know you don't like talking about
Sam's origin story but I have three
questions that maybe you could answer
the first is I just want to know is
there any person on this planet that
you've revealed Sam's full arent so
literally no one knows it only exists in
your head yes okay I'm going to try for
two other little bits of details right
now one is Sam Immortal can anything
kill Sam I'm not gonna answer that
question either I had a feeling I have
to try for these leaning towards
Immortal okay I'll take that because if
he if he dies like actually one thing
I'll give you is that I like to think
that cuz we have done a short that sort
of establishes this um Fearnet used to
run the movie for 24 hours on Halloween
and so they commissioned uh me to create
like a series of short films to help
promote it and so one short we showed we
called it November 1st it showed like
the aftermath of a Halloween party you
go into a backyard you see decorations
costumes everywhere and then you see
Sam's dead body like you see like this
like wilted withered corpse of what was
Sam in his pajamas and you see sort of
like the pumpkin seeds and guts like
laying in the dirt and then you see one
seed sort of like
Giggle and like implant itself into the
dirt so in my mind he dies every
November
1st but with the help of certain others
certain seeds or guts are retained and
then he's he grows back every October
I'll follow that up with one other
question does that mean multiple Sams
could grow no okay I'll give you that
rule one one one one and only um let's
go to another creature design because
you already brought up the uh the
werewolf segment and like a werewolf
transformation is one of the most
difficult things to pull off on screen
it either works or it doesn't there's no
middle ground with something like that
so maybe when you were approaching
designing all of that can you give us
some dos and don'ts for nailing a
werewolf transformation I would say
don't solely rely on CG because it'll
look like crap um if you can you should
use a mix of practical animatronic
makeup effects enhanced with CG
sweetened a little bit which is what we
did um but other than that like nothing
really beats just good oldfashioned like
foam latex I will very much agree with
that in general and one of the things
that I love about this movie is how well
it holds up like it looks just as good
today as it did the day that I saw it
and you know we're kind of we're kind of
obsessed with modern technology and
finding new fancy things to make our
movies so can you maybe give us an
example of a technique you used to
create this movie back when you first
made it that you still find useful today
that you wish more filmmakers would use
instead of leaning towards you know big
budgets fancy tools and all those kinds
of things shooting on film that's one uh
there's still a warmth to actual film
that is so hard to find with digital um
that's a really good question trying to
think of what
else help me out a little bit I like any
kind of practical creature element
um did I did I hear something in another
interview where you used a miniature for
the bus going over too oh yeah that was
a miniature that stuff is great well the
it's a correction it's it's a mix of two
things so we did throw an actual short
bus over a cliff so the shot from behind
where you see it like Zoom away from
camera and go over that's a real bus and
then the camera pushed and like tilted
and looked down an actual Cliff but we
then for the sinking where it disappears
in the water that's a minute
so it looks like one shot but the the
shot once it like goes and peers into
the Rock Corey that's where it became
the miniature That Was Then Blended in
with uh VFX and that miniature is on
display at the Mystic Museum in Burbank
if you want to see it so they have the
miniature School Bus they have Charlie
severed head um on a platter uh and I
think they've got some candy maybe the
suckers some other stuff but they have a
whole amazing like giant Sam you can get
a picture of and yeah that is where you
can all find me tomorrow also I mean
this isn't uh this isn't any kind of
like fancy tool specifically but it's
also just just the way you shoot and you
edit a lot of the stuff because a lot a
lot of those reveals only work because
of the way you cut like in particular
you bring up his head on a platter that
works really well because of the framing
that you used and when you cut to the
reveal everything is pitch it's simple
well I have to give credit to my
storyboard artist um very talented
gentleman named Simeon Wilkins uh we
worked a long time boarding all of it
together I love using storyboards some
filmmakers just like to shoot on the Fly
and that's great too but um the fun of
storyboards is that and it was really
essential for getting the movie Green
lit because remember this is my first
movie and so there was some skepticism
and doubt so I just started bombarding
the studio Executives with concept art
and storyboards and then on the day when
we're shooting just had them print it up
and we just cross off each one don't
know how this is your first feature huh
I don't know how this is your first
feature it really blows my mind broader
question about this now of all the
segments in the movie going into
production which did you think would be
most challenging to pull off and then
ultimately was that indeed the toughest
of the bunch or did a different one
Catch You by surprise another good
question I would say the rock Corey was
daunting because it was so many kids was
multiple locations in some ways the
scale of that one is the biggest you
know because the Sam versus Brian Cox
stuff like that's just one house you
know two characters and that was the
rule for a lot of it um one rule that we
had uh at film school was that for your
short film keep it to two characters one
location right because that like those
creative constraints sort of in a way
force you to be more creative to create
something intriguing with a smaller
scale and smaller cast but the the rock
Corey story it's like okay well we're on
the streets the kids are
trick-or-treating so it was just
daunting cuz like just the scale
multiple occasions multiple characters
and the flashback contained within it
you know so that one's like the most
sprawling one I think you were kind of
uh hinting at something like this
earlier on in one of your answers but
can you maybe pinpoint a day on set when
things weren't going to plan you had to
find a way to Pivot and you wound up
finding unexpected magic that made a
scene better than what you had
originally
planned oh jeez this is like a million
years ago I'm like tell me about every
single day I mean just as an example
like um we shot this in
Vancouver uh starting in early November
to early January and I don't know if you
guys ever been in Vancouver but it rains
nonstop literally 247 pretty much from
October until spring and I was besides
myself cuz like how am I going to shoot
a Halloween movie you know when it's
pouring rain that's not part of the
script and we got to the point where we
had to shoot the school bus flashback
and it was just torrential right and it
was meant to be very sunny and golden
hour throughout like we had in the film
and I was convinced that we'd have to
pull the plug and I swear to God it was
the weirdest thing out of the blue the
skies cleared the sun came out and we
got to shoot everything and then like I
called cut and then started raining
again it's meant to be yeah I sacrificed
a goat the night before but that makes
sense that makes sense again I would
believe it yeah so when you finished
filming the movie of all the segments
which one was your favorite and now all
these years later is that still your
favorite or has one grown on you more
than you ever expected it to that's like
asking to pick your favorite child oh
I'm gonna ask you to pick your favorite
child a couple times I
mean Sam versus cre a little bit because
it's Sam like I love working with the
guy um and Brian Cox because he's also
fun to work with uh but that's the thing
is like it was a great shooting it was a
wonderful experience um it it's just
hard to pick it's fair I get it I mean
clearly I know my answer but they're all
they're all wonderful here's my other
favorite child question we'll get it out
of the way do you have a single favorite
frame of this movie oo
um
God I don't I can't think of one
honestly there are many good ones I am
obsessed with one of the school bus
Massacre ones where it's right after the
The Story Goes from past to present and
you have all five of them right on the
edge of the Quarry and then it cuts to a
side view of them I just love that oh
interesting something about that to me
is just like chilling coming out of that
story and then seeing them there and
knowing what lies ahead for them okay so
you can you can have my answer
sure um you brought up Brian Cox so I
will go there next what was his first
reaction when you pitched him that role
uh he has I have one request I want to
look like John carero
okay Brian whatever you want did he tell
you why that was his one request uh I
mean because he he saw it you know
rightfully as sort of uh in the
tradition of Halloween like he knew that
there would be no trick-or treat if it
wasn't for John Carpenter and Halloween
so I think he wanted to pay tribute to
the master so he went off and worked
with a makeup artist to come up with uh
the sort of hooked nose and the scar and
the scraggly hair and all of that but
then he learned to regret it because it
took hours to apply all that stuff and
so then at the when we finally wrapped
him he literally reached up and started
ripping the fake skin off of his face
saying never again never again I have a
million follow-up questions I'm trying
to keep track of everything another
thing about Brian Cox's performance in
this that I love is his uh like his scar
scene reactions like his screams are
just so spot-on and perfect and his
reactions to everything Sam does feel so
like truly him do you have any memories
from set where I don't know whether it's
like the moment where he's like oh when
he sees Sam skitter across the top of
the stairs or when he's like biting into
his leg just something where he went so
big and you're like like damn like
you're you're scream queen level
here's great no he's just he's he's one
of my favorite actors to work with cuz
he's so easygoing but he's kind of
cranky a little bit you know he's kind
of a Crogan in real life but you love
him um he tell you to off King
I to it so that YouTube doesn't ruin our
video no no no um but no he's he's he's
a blast to work with and he's been
hugely supportive of the movie from the
very beginning like he would do he was
down to go to ComiCon and screen it
there and do q&as I mean Brian Cox is
the best he's the original handable
Lector I don't know if you guys know
that I want to ask about every single
member of this Ensemble but we don't
have time so I love I love talking here
I can get at at least two people this
way I love talking about the different
acting processes that there are out
there can you maybe pin point two
members of this Ensemble with completely
different approaches to the work where
it called for something different from
you as their actor's director wait what
where they where they have different
ways that they like to work so you had
to adjust what you were doing for them
as their director no it honestly no it
was the most easygoing cast everybody
was just down for anything like no Divas
I mean it was you know so many kids um
but you know Anna pacin were like
absolutely down for anything thing like
here put these contacts in we need to
give you some fangs like just loved it
can you give us an example of a Time on
set when someone went above and beyond
with the material and did something that
you didn't anticipate uh Quinn Lord all
the time like he really got into
character to the point that his parents
were worried if I remember correctly
like they came to set one day like yeah
he's staying in character when we take
him home like we're a little concerned
he's hiding under beds you know kind of
appreciate that though absolutely I want
to go back to School Bus Massacre for
one other question because I heard you
say once that I think it was the Buddha
mask was a gift from someone in your
family I have a lot of questions about
this actually like why was that a gift
was it a gift specifically for the movie
or do they just know that you like masks
I don't know like half my family is
Vietnamese so uh that was part of like a
like a New Year's celebration okay and I
think one of my cousins made it out of
papier-mâché and like sent it to me in a
box it's all I remember and I thought
well this is kind of creepy I'm gonna
put this in the movie that's awesome
that it's in the movie now well that's a
replica of the one that they sent me I
was I was gonna say because then you'd
run the risk of ruining it yeah what
about the other ones can you tell us
some of like the creative inspiration
behind why you chose those particular
looks for the other masks um I just try
to come up with masks that felt like
children actually made I mean I'm a huge
fan of the history and lore of Halloween
and you know before we had like Don post
or Spirit Halloween masks if you go back
and you look at like you know Halloween
as it was celebrated in the 20s through
the 40s it's a lot of like paper mâché
and just bags and you know glue and
random stuff just sort of thrown
together and it's just Eerie way
creepier than we have now so I I just
thought like what would have happened if
a group of disturbed children were given
some basic you know materials to make
their own masks and costumes with is it
safe to assume you've kept stuff from
set um I was gifted some things I never
stole anything I didn't um uh yes I I
have some key items for sure you not
tell us what they are cuz now I'm even
more Curious no I'm not going to say you
guys are apparently putting this on
YouTube you know like no it's I already
said an F bomb no one's goingon to be
able to watch it now yeah no I've got
some Treasures okay okay all right do
you want you want the question that Here
Comes This is the new Halloween
tradition I can't help it I can't help
it every single year
room just go for it go for it is there
any update on the sequel has there been
any forward momentum at all I know like
this is the new Halloween tradition it's
like drag Mike dhy out of the Halloween
decorations box what's going on with the
sequel and I have to be all evasive then
there's like you know
articles I me this is going back since
the beginning of the movie coming out um
and I'm I'm not trying to sound a this I
I'll say this like cuz we said it last
year at the Beyond pest screening the
sequel is in Act development with
legendary um I'll go so far as to say
that we have several drafts of a script
uh I brought back the same storyboard
artist I mentioned before Simeon Wilkins
so we have a stack of storyboards um and
a good fat stack a concept art done by
Brien Burns as well um so it's inching
along um hoping to talk to Legendary
they've been wonderful like great
collaborators but so much of it is
timing and as you know we just got out
of a strike uh so the next step fingers
crossed would be looking at budget of
course um schedule and all the rest but
we have a a really really great script
for a sequel I'm gonna ask yeah I'll
applaud for that I'll ask two more I'm
sorry I brought in my my co-writer from
Krampus to do it with me so uh Zack
Shields and Todd Casey who did Krampus
with me also helped me write trick-or
treat part two
love crampus is that what you're going
to call it trick-or treat part two just
well we don't know yet it's just the
working title the working jez that just
like came out the working title trick-
or- treat too and um came up with a
proper Nemesis for Sam that would give
Brian Cox a run for his
money I have so many questions this is
so hard I'll I'll ask you one sequel
question that I think you can kind of
talk about just in terms of I mean like
why did it take so long other than
things like like the strike and those
kinds of setback because like again look
at this crowd look at people that are
obsessed with your movies Sam's in every
single store why wasn't this expedited
and made a top priority because I don't
want it to be crap good answer yeah like
that answer I love all of our favorite
horror franchise characters as much as
any of us you know but not all of them
are great you know like and I know we've
grown to love even like the Lesser
chapters of our favorite horror series
um there's always like a cheese value to
them but like if I'm going to do a
sequel I want it to be as good if not
better than the original and good things
take time um and the last thing I would
want is to see you know like trick-or
treat part nine Sam goes to space you
know although that does have potential I
will say never watched that all right
here's the question you can't answer but
it's crossed my mind is there any chance
Billy could come back for a trick-or
cheet sequel um anything is possible but
like I definitely prefer leaning into
the idea that every sequel um would
stand alone MH um that would bring a new
cast of characters uh with Sam being
sort of the consistent one among them
all I'll throw in one other question
because you brought up Krampus and I'm
also obsessed with crampus did you ever
think about making a sequel to that like
I would love to see how another family
behaved during an encounter with Krampus
we have an idea for a sequel on that one
too um it doesn't necessarily center
around a family as as much as it might
be about a group of strangers who are
trapped somewhere can we just keep you
in Holiday horror forever like coming
soon Mike dy's
Passover I would watch that too I know
the angel of death is terrifying I I
mean I also genuinely want Hanukkah har
too yeah I'll take all of it absolutely
all right I'm gonna throw it out to the
audience we're going to get to as many
questions as we possibly can who I see
that's the first hand I see all the way
in the back yeah Brian
says you got to be kidding me is
that homage of sour to John thing you
think yeah it is
absolutely all right up front here uh so
you did Krampus and trick-or tree is
there any other holiday you would like
to make a movie
about I don't know what do you guys
think I think you should do a leprechaun
I feel like you could do I think
leprechaun just got taken I think Lion's
gate is doing leprechaun I thought
Easter could be kind of fun
yeah a lot of people shouting Easter
yeah okay that's zombie Jus it's creepy
you
know right up front here two questions
really quick um can you tell us can you
tell us um were some of the storyboards
used um that you that you created there
also used for the comic book um scenes
that also POS yes and then next question
is uh well if you could just tell us a
little bit more about the costume design
because I know know that the gsy on the
werewolf Gs are going into stored by
costumes those are obviously not stored
by costumes I think all the costumes
here are beautiful and I know you
touched upon the mass of some of the
children if you could talk about maybe
some of the other costumes and maybe
some of the work you did with the
costume designer and come up with some
of the ideas and the themes um so I
don't know if you guys heard that most
of it was about the the costumes in the
film um yeah so the intention was to
have the girls all dressed to sort of
different classic storybook characters
um and I know that they don't look like
store bot like maybe they look like
store rentals um but the idea is they
should just look beautiful and look
reminiscent of uh certain classic fairy
tale characters without being sued by a
certain Mouse um uh but no like the the
idea is that every story like costumes
sort of had their own particular look so
the uh the werewolf story obviously
we're leaning into sort of the the
sexual fantasy of Halloween and what
Halloween is like in your 20s um I you
know with the with the kids and the rock
cories well what is Halloween in your
adolescent years because I don't know
about you guys but like I had just very
distinct memories like you spend your
early Halloweens going trick-or-treating
with your family you know like with Mom
and Dad and maybe your brothers or
sisters and then you you move to a level
where you then start to venture out with
your friends you know so if you really
look at the movie like everyone is
structured Ed um to go to study
Halloween through the different stages
of Life all the way up until Brian Cox's
story and he's just this disheveled
decrepit hermit living by himself and
the costumes were all sort of meant to
reflect those different stages of
Life what's the most random thing you've
ever dressed up as for
Halloween a cow I think okay yeah okay
why' you choose a cow I don't remember
don't no memory of it I I used to
remember I used to work in a costume
shop in high school that's what it was
so I worked in a costume shop and we had
like three costumes to pick from and a
cow had like the UDS sort of like
hanging right between the legs um anyway
next question good choice uh let's go in
the middle here when I first saw the
movie two years ago I was ecstatic to
hear Marilyn Manson's sweet dream start
playing I know that was not the first
song you wanted for that scene how did
it get in there and what was the
reaction so the werewolf transformation
was um originally set to Fever by Peggy
Lee so um when it came time to shoot
that scene I just needed a track for the
girls to sort of dance and and strip
tease to and uh I think I heard fever on
the radio or something I thought this
could be kind of fun and so then we
tried a cut with it so was also edited
to Fever um and it just didn't have the
same punch you know it didn't feel quite
as
Fierce uh as sweet dreams and I was
initially very against changing I kept
pushing for fever but I kind of came to
my senses when an editor came in and
just sort of recut it to sweet dreams I
was like all right that works yeah can't
see it any other way now yeah all right
let's go back
there yeah yeah you so in the beginning
of the film when Sam has his trick bag I
noticed that when he PS down the stairs
you can hear the cats in the back and as
a cat that after ask this question is
that because cat the prot of the
underworld and so that allows the
spirits to come back out the cats turn
the back that's a really specific
question um
I that was in actually inspired by
something Quinn Lord did so when Quinn
Lord auditioned for Sam uh he was
amazing uh and I said just just do
something that that that you think Sam
would do and he thought about it for a
second and then he minded um I'm trying
to think of like exactly the word he
used he started going like come here
kitty kitty and he pretend to grab it
and then like walk away with it um and
so I thought would would be funny if
like Sam had a in my mind he's got a
black hat in his bag and it's not that
he like he's taking it home to eat it or
anything like that's his pet black hat
you know which might or might not
already be dead but resurrected in a
weird way maybe we'll see that in the
sequel um but in my in my mind the bag
is a sort of full a bag of tricks and
sort of weapons and Minions that he can
sort of pull from yeah there's anything
that would make me love Sam more it
would be confirmation that he has a pet
black cat whether that cat is
resurrected or just alive yeah it's
probably resurrected okay I'll take that
all right let's go right over there yeah
yeah s uh so sometimes what you put on a
page can end up feeling different when
you're actually seeing it be performed
so as the writer and director I curi how
you find the right moments to insert a
joke when Mak a movie like this oh I
mean I like to use humor and horror
together I like to use humor to sort of
um get the audience to lower its guard
um I I find that humor is a good way
because you obviously when you sit down
to watch a horror movie you're either
consciously even subconsciously sort of
bracing yourself and um anticipating the
scares right and I've just found that
like one of my fav movies is Poltergeist
and what the first like 15 minutes of
that movie does so well uh is that it
uses humor to kind of relax you you know
and disarm you so that when the when the
horror does start to creep into the
movie uh it's even more potent it's more
effective so I find that they're they're
great bed fellows because the contrast
between the two makes it really
effective um so same thing here it's
like sprinkling a little bit of humor
here and there I find just sort of hits
like a mental reset button for people so
that if if you're keep if you're keeping
the fear and the dread and the horror at
a 10 all the time you kind of become
numb to it in some ways all right let's
see if we can get a couple more back
there first so you mentioned that you
weren't able to get Studios to Green
Light movie with the icons before how
were you able to get them around you as
a firsttime filmmaker and how much time
was it between that first go around that
didn't get movie Green and when you
actually got the movie Green so I don't
know if you guys heard that but he asked
you know if I couldn't get the icons of
horror couldn't get the movie Green lit
with the icons of horror how did they
get it how did I get it green lit with
me of all people basically
right yeah so again sacrificing goats
works miracles you have no idea um no
uh I
think I I don't know if there was any
one thing necessarily um part of of it
was because legendary pictures loved the
script so much and I had worked with
them um on Superman Returns as a writer
and I got to know the the founder Thomas
TL really well um as well as John jashne
so John jashne he read the script when
it went out initially and ultimately his
company passed on it but he did love the
script and he just wasn't in a position
where he could buy it and get it made at
the where at the company that he was
working at so when John jashne went to
Legendary he remembered the script he
goes I still love it would you be
interested and you know would you
consider directing it um in some ways
you know Hollywood's a funny place where
it's like they almost would rather give
um a first time director a shot because
every a lot of Executives they want to
feel like they discovered somebody you
know or they sort of helped give you
that first opportunity um so I think
that was part of it and then I was
coming off the success of you know again
being a writer on uh X-Men 2 and on
Superman so I think they kind of felt
like they were part of something new but
old at the same time I'm again this is
all speculation on my part but it was
about six years between writing the
first draft that initially got rejected
by all the studios um and then shooting
uh with me behind the camera I'll
squeeze in a somewhat similar question
cuz like it's important that someone
believed in you and gave you the
opportunity to make your first feature
so have you seen anything recently from
a rising voice in the genre space that
you're really excited about and want to
make sure everyone knows their name now
um yes there's so much amazing new
horror I mean I am a complete for
a24 horror I will just say it you're
going I feel like they're doing it right
I mean I'm I'm of the mindset that if
you if we M made Rosemary's Baby or The
Exorcist today they'd probably actually
be a24 horror movies because a24 will
let your movies breathe you know
hereditary is is one of my favorites um
but a lesser known a24 horror flick that
didn't get the same attention as um like
talk to me or some more recent ones as
St mod I don't know if you saw that one
so good I loved St mod that's that's my
Catholic guilt coming out sorry Rose
glass rose glass yeah Rose glass morphid
Clark oh my God it's it's phenomenal um
especially if you're carrying any any
kind of religious guilt uh it's all
about St mod it it didn't get the
attention to deserve because I think it
came out like just as the P we were all
freaking out about the pandemic yeah
that sounds about right seek that movie
out if you have not seen it um maybe we
can squeeze in one more I I'll go for
the first hand I saw right in the middle
in the back thank you I wanted to ask
about the cinematography there you are
storyboarded uh the entire movie um
there are a lot of movement moving shots
specifically some crane shots like
Ukraine over fire into a closeup so I
want I hope you can talk more about that
process CU there a lot of
amazing yeah a lot of the crane shots
and camera movements were boarded um my
my guy Simeon he's a rock star about you
know indicating like where to zoom where
to Crane Dolly all of that stuff um and
we talk about it extensively and that's
where good planning really helps you
know cuz crane days are expensive you
know um uh and so when you can pinpoint
exactly when you want to use one on set
it's immensely helpful um but also a lot
of it a lot of it was done because we
were just running out of time so like he
just had to you know whip the camera and
use a crane um because the clock's
ticking you'd be so shocked at like how
much creative Innovation just comes out
of um being squeezed for
time like the whole scene of Anna pin
walking through the parade you know
where she's sort of like looking for her
next date SL victim initially that was
like three separate scenes where she
goes up to like three different people
and has these sort of brief interactions
and conversations with them and the line
producer came to me I think it was like
two pages worth of of scenes of her just
sort of interacting with possible
victims like she was interviewing them
flirting with them and the lion producer
came out to me goes okay well we've got
you know two three pages left and we
have exactly 20
minutes and I said fine it's going to be
two shots it's going to be her walking
and then the reverse and we'll just see
all the people that she's zeroing in on
and that's it gets the job got you got
the job done so that happens a lot yeah
all right Mike we got to let you go
thank you guys I just want to tell you
how much I appreciate you coming out you
could have stayed home and watched us on
HBO Max by the way but you didn't you
came and means a lot to me thank you all
for coming out tonight and I'll remind
you we got two more screenings left
we've got final girls and lights out
next week at the sunset location go buy
tickets Mike thank you again for being
here with us
tonight